حاله استنفار الاستيعاب المرضى في هذا
المستشفى في مقاطعه بالصينيه منذ الغاء
سياسه صفر كوفيت سجلت زياده هائله في
اعداد المصابين بالفيروس
يستخدمه كل اقسام
الجراحه والطب الاسنان
واستدعينا الموظفين المتقاعدين وجميع
الحاصلين على شهادات الطب او التمريض
والصينيه بدات تتخلص
منها
وسيلغى الحجر الصحي للوافدين الى الصين
اعتبارا من اليوم الثامن من الشهر المقبل
وذلك في محاوله للتعايش مع الفيروس بدلا
من القضاء على العدوى وهو بالطبع ما اسعد
قطاع السياحه الذي تنفس السعداء بعد ثلاث
سنوات من الاختناق
كما اعلنت سلطات الهجره الصينيه عن
استئناف منح جوازات السفر لاغراض السياحه
وزياره الاصدقاء في الخارج بعد ان كان منح
جوازات مقتصرا على من لديهم حالات طوارئ
عائليه او عمل هامه بعض وسائل الاعلام
الغربيه
في الصين بينما تتجنب الحديث عن اوجه
القصور والثمن الباهض لسياسات كوزيت في
بلدانها هذا كيلون بمكيالين ولا يتوافقوا
مع الاخلاق الصحفيه
من البلدان فتح الحدود الصينيه في وقت
تواجه الصين احدى اوسع موجات الاصابات في
العالم
السلطات الامريكيه قالت انها تنظر في
احتمال فرض قيود على الوافدين من الصين
وسارعت الهند واليابان وماليزيا الى فرض
فحوصات بي سي ار الزاميه على كل القادمين
اليها من الصين